la sécurité l'immigration sont hors de
contrôle aujourd'hui en france et que
nous sommes en train d'ouvrir un débat
sous les blés chouine riz de la gauche
et de l'extrême gauche parce que le
ministre de l'intérieur s'apprête à
expulser un clandestin est-ce que je
reçois le lucky luke du tweet c'est pas
moi qui utilise cette expression c'est
un policier qu'est-ce que vous avez
monsieur ligne je vous entends pas dit
si
je croyais qu'il fallait pas interrompre
les intervenants mais apparemment c'est
autorisé pour le ministre
je vous demande de poursuivre votre
intervention s'il vous plaît c'est moi
qui dirige cette séance la france est
livrée à un chaos sécuritaire et
migratoire qui est devenu aujourd'hui
hors de contrôle et les responsables de
cette violence le responsable
aujourd'hui de ce désordre ces messieurs
darmanin et dupond moretti qui ne tienne
absolument plus rien que je regrette
absolument rien de ce que j'ai pu
annoncer hier d'abord parce que les
policiers ont été agressés manière
absolue
aussi de faire remarquer des choses
comme vous ne le faites pas madame la
présidente écoutez vous n'avez pas à
remettre en cause ma présidence donc ne
me dise pas que
je veux dire aux français que notre main
ne tremble pas et que je suis mais très
étonné qu'une certaine extrême gauche
tiennent plus avec des délinquants
qu'avec les policiers dans le cas
présent ça va tout le monde et défouler
je peux y aller merci bon bah écoutez
votre tour étaient tous les machins
collègues les deux minutes sont passées
ni baisse ralentit les débats de façon
assez considérable en mettant des
amendements complètement délirant en
faisant des propositions
chiffrées complètement hallucinante
l'air d'un parlement chambre
d'enregistrement des desiderata du
président de la république est révolu
moi je n'avais pas le souvenir d'avoir
vu autant de députés dans l'hémicycle
tard le soir ou dans la nuit nous
assistons je le dis très calmement un
vrai dévoiement du débat démocratique
fait qu on peut être les français
peuvent être troublé mais ça fait partie
du débat parlementaire vous êtes un
journaliste d'expérience vous allez pas
me faire croire que vous découvrez qu'à
l'assemblée des femmes et des hommes qui
sont élus sur des convictions
éventuellement ce pas défendre avec
passion leurs arguments mettez vous à la
place de nos compatriotes qui auraient
eu le courage de suivre nos débats
jusqu'à cette heure tardive de la lune
et qui se serait dit tiens je vais
regarder ce que les élus du peuple à qui
j'ai confié ma souveraineté sont en
train de décider pour mon pouvoir
d'achat et qui nous voient avoir des
débats interminables sur le nombre de
pompiers qu'il faut recruter ajoutez à
cela le débat qui monte depuis plusieurs
jours sur la tenue vestimentaire de
certains députés qui ne serait pas
correct l'élu heller eric ciotti a
demandé le port obligatoire de la
cravate lors des séances en réponse à
cette provocation plusieurs femmes de la
france insoumise sont arrivés
aujourd'hui justement en veste et
cravate est un nouveau revers pour le
gouvernement à l'assemblée nationale
lors de l'examen des mesures pour le
pouvoir d'achat les groupes d'opposition
se sont associés pour voter 230 millions
d'euros de soutien aux foyers se
chauffant au fioul
faut quand même expliqué que les
enveloppes de l'état sont pas illimitées
on peut pas voter des enveloppes de 200
400 500 millions à un milliard de
milliards 3 milliards on n'est pas au
loto parce qu'au final c'est sur le
budget de l'état et donc c'est sûr les
français parce que le budget de l'état
c'est la poche des français et bien sûr
mais vous savez quand vous êtes en mode
survie que les retraités ont 8 euros par
jour allez leur dire mais ma bonne dame
se serait bien de changer votre votre
système de chauffage vous savez bien que
c'est quand même beaucoup plus compliqué
que ça la russie en afrique a beaucoup
diffusé des fausses informations elles
est en train d'ouvrir les officines que
son rochette des scouts ni que nous
venons d'interdire en europe et dont
nous savons combien le diffuse des
fausses informations sur le sol africain
ces derniers mois la france avait misé
sur l'anticipation pour éviter une
pénurie énergétique cet hiver elle a
fait des réserves de gaz russes
notamment mais c'était sans compter sur
la récente décision du kremlin de couper
le robinet pour leur dire nous vous
apportons sécurité et protection à vous
pas votre peuple à vous
en échange d'une influence russe et
d'une captation des matières premières
hier le saint-père par trois fois à
demander pardon aux milliers de
personnes victimes d'abus physiques
verbaux psychologique spirituel dans les
pensionnats pour autochtones pendant un
petit peu plus d'un siècle un des
excuses très attendu par les populations
amérindiennes qui vivent au canada salut
[Musique]